jojo's bizarre adventure is one of the
most popular anime series around fans
especially love the villains and rightly
so the rogue's gallery is as flamboyant
and fantastic as its heroes but which
villains reign supreme we've ranked them
from worst to best so let's take a look
one of the many assassins dispatched by
dio brando to destroy the star crusaders
in the third season jay guile has a
direct connection to the heroes at the
center of the story it's a dark one he
assaulted and killed jean-pierre
polnareff's sister sherry this makes him
a more central part of the story than
one might expect of a minor villain
there are two main characteristics that
make j guile stand out the first is his
distinctive physiology he has two right
hands the second is his stand hanged man
a potent light-based power that can jump
from one reflective surface to another j
guile makes wicked use of his abilities
killing protagonists joturo cujo's
friend muhammad abdul and nearly killing
polnarep himself thankfully he is
defeated thanks to quick thinking and
manipulation of his stand by noriyaki
kakyoin
enjiro katagiri is one of the creepiest
jojo bad guys around appearing in
diamond is unbreakable he's a lifelong
criminal convicted of robbery rape and
murder by the age of 12. he spent the
next 20 years in and out of prison
eventually landing himself on death row
just before his execution a mysterious
stranger shot him with the bow and arrow
which granted him the stand aqua
necklace which enabled his escape he
proves a formidable foe for jotaro cujo
and josuke higashikata until they trick
his stand into being captured and fused
the diabolical angelo with a rock his
depraved criminality knows no bounds
whether he's killing children or biting
the face off of a dog his stand aqua
necklace made entirely of water is able
to evade detection by merging with
puddles and streams change shape and
work its way into the bodies of angelo's
victims either possessing or outright
killing them from within it's a gruesome
power in the hands of a gruesome man who
fortunately falls in battle early on in
the heroes quest
daniel j darby one of dio's assassins is
dispatched to defeat jotaro cujo while
his stand osiris allows him to steal
other souls he prefers to gamble for
them in games of chance games he
inevitably attempts to fix it's only
thanks to joturo's incredible ability to
bluff and poker that he's defeated and
the souls he stole set free what makes
darby stand out other than his excellent
taste in vests is that unlike a lot of
jojo's bizarre adventure villains he
isn't the type to be beaten in physical
combat his suave intelligence allows him
to steal the souls of half the stardust
crusaders team and very nearly defeat
jotaro entirely he is of course bluffed
into catatonia folding on four kings
during a poker hand in which the hero
never once looks at his cards i can't do
it i'm petrified i'm too terrified to
say the words
first of all steely dan gets major props
for his moniker which is an overt
reference to the jazz influenced 1970s
rock group of the same name but it's
dan's stand the lovers that really puts
him over the top microscopic in size it
crawls into its victim's ear and
attaches itself to the brain stem where
it uses its power to cause any attack on
steely dan to be reflected back to the
attacker magnified oh and it can also
implant dio's flesh buds and murder its
host from within jojo's bizarre
adventure really builds up viewer
animosity for steely dan during his
brief appearance in stardust crusaders
by using the lovers on joturo's
grandfather joseph joestar he holds our
hero hostage threatening to hurt him if
he doesn't obey dan's bidding humiliated
beaten and forced to rob a jewelry store
while the villain gloats jotaro is
eventually able to make steely dan pay
once his companions manage to free
joseph from the lovers all this buildup
makes steely dance defeat one of the
most satisfying dispatches of a bad guy
in the show's entire run
some characters in jojo's bizarre
adventure possess stands so powerful and
impressive they strike fear into the
heart of anyone who has to face them
tara nosuke miyamoto is not one of those
characters even this minor villain from
diamond is unbreakable admits that his
enigma power which allows him to turn
someone into paper if he can identify
the mannerisms that show they're afraid
is kind of lame what makes this
particular baddie so impressive though
is the mileage he manages to get out of
such an unimpressive stand when he
encounters josuke and his companions he
very quickly manages to learn their
individual expressions of fear trapping
the heroes in paper form one at a time
then it's just a matter of deploying a
convenient paper shredder to create a
perilous situation that is only narrowly
averted thankfully josuke and his team
are saved and they exact a particularly
fitting vengeance trapping miyamoto in
the form of a book which the hero then
donates to a library he's not the most
powerful villain a joestar has ever
faced but there's no better example of
making evil lemonade out of lemons stand
wise
appearing in stardust crusaders hall
horse has the myan of a cool gunslinger
and his stand emperor is pretty awesome
taking the form of a pistol with bullets
he can redirect however he's one of the
most ineffective and cowardly villains
in the long history of jojo's bizarre
adventure hall horse runs away the
moment he lacks villainous backup hired
by dio brando to assassinate jotaro cujo
he's several times a thorn in the side
of our heroes but always ends up
thwarted so why is he not at the top of
the list well there are villains who
scare you and villains who amuse you and
hall horse definitely falls into that
latter category his foolishness and
unwillingness to pardon the pun take a
stand without backup leads to his plans
falling through in hilarious ways even
his demise is ridiculous as his broken
watch leads to him messing up one of
boingo's prophecies firing emperor into
a pipe at the wrong time and shooting
himself instead of jotaro the gun is
mightier than the sword
such a brilliant quote
the list of passionate members who take
on giorno giovanna and buchiarati's crew
in golden wind is long but none make
quite as much of an impression as this
hot-headed ice-wielding assassin his
stand white album is not only named
after one of the best records of all
time it's versatile and potent and
giacho knows how to use it to deadly
effect it's simple at root allowing the
wielder to freeze anything he touches
but when giacho deploys it to do
everything from ice skate to solidify
the moisture in the air it proves a
significant challenge for giorno to
overcome oh and it also serves as
impenetrable full body armor of course
like any great power white album comes
with a weakness a small air hole at the
back of the neck you might not think
that would be of enough significance to
be exploitable but it very much is
fortunately for the good guys a
conveniently placed splintered lamp post
impales giaco and saves their hides the
killer doesn't go out without a fight
though attempting to freeze his own
blood in order to stay alive long enough
to make one last ditch attempt at
victory it's short-lived and a chilling
conclusion for passionate's most
memorable enforcer a member of a
powerful and ancient race of superhuman
beings known as the pillarmen karz is
the main antagonist in the second part
of battle tendency he takes a lot of the
big bad boxes he's so evil he kills his
own people he's super powerful and he
has insane goals of manipulating an
ancient artifact the stone mask which he
creates in an effort to maximize the
potential of the pillar men's powers to
become the ultimate life form
treacherous and relentless he wields
considerable power in his quest to
complete the stone mask including an
effect called light mode that creates
chainsaw-esque blades that can cut
through solid stone what makes cars
really cool however is the fact that he
actually achieves his goal that's right
he really does manage to complete the
stone mask and don it to become the
ultimate life form it's only through a
stroke of desperate instinct that joseph
joestar is able to redirect one of
carr's attacks in order to create a
massive volcanic eruption that launches
the pillar man into space there he
freezes and drifts away from earth
doomed to forever float through the void
vanilla ice's name is one of the more on
the nose musical references in jojo's
bizarre adventure but make no mistake
this guy means business his most
impressive characteristic is his slavish
devotion to his boss the vampire
diobrando let's face it as a top line
villain you can't do much better than a
henchman who is literally willing to
slice off his own head to make you happy
as vanilla ice does for diobrando in
stardust crusaders he's immediately
resurrected as a vampire and goes on to
viciously attack the crusaders beating
iggy to death and nearly taking out
polnareff one piece at a time when he's
not busy sacrificing his life or
engaging in animal cruelty vanilla ice
wields the powerful stand cream which
yes is named for the 1960s rock band
featuring eric clapton cream creates a
sphere of void that swallows its user
making him invincible and wiping out
anything it comes across while it does
have the weakness of making ice unable
to see while he's using it cream proves
very potent and it's only thanks to
vanilla ice's lack of experience with
his vampiric form that the crusaders are
able to defeat him once and for all
really just look at this guy even among
the mighty pillarmen his physique stands
out especially since wamu has no problem
showing it off in a variety of poses if
his body is impressive however it's his
heart that really sets him apart while
he's indisputably a villain he possesses
a clear moral code and a respect for the
honor that comes with battle he's a man
of his word uninterested in the
immortality that motivates cars and keen
on respecting the enemies who prove
themselves against him he also refuses
to harm children which really makes him
stand out in the world of jojo's bizarre
adventure villains simply put while cars
might be battle tendencies biggest
threat wamu is its most interesting he
uses his divine sandstorm power to
defeat joseph joestar but accepts the
hero's challenge of a rematch a month
later then he faces caesar in a
massively compelling fight that ends
thanks once more to define sandstorm in
the hero's demise his final battle with
joseph a lengthy and violent chariot
race is one of the more exciting moments
in the series
the shadow dio brando casts over the
events of jojo's bizarre adventure is
huge he's the series most important
villain the antagonist for numerous
generations of the joestar family and
quite possibly one of the nastiest bad
guys in anime his list of transgressions
prior to using the stone mask to become
an immortal vampire is heinous enough
but things only get worse once he comes
into his power said power includes eye
lasers healing abilities a freezing
touch and topping it all his time
stopping stand the world simply put
diobrando is bad news he's also the main
villain in two separate jojo's bizarre
adventure series first in his attempt to
usurp the joe star fortune in phantom
blood and then in a reincarnated form in
stardust crusaders through it all he
displays a ruthlessness cunning and
bloodlust that sets him above and beyond
every other bad guy in the series taking
countless lives and wreaking endless
havoc oh and he's the reason the
joestars develop stan powers which play
a pivotal role in the show from the
moment of their introduction every
jojo's bizarre adventure villain has his
or her own importance to the story as a
whole but for the sheer impact and evil
there's no beating dio brando with my
stand i have the ability to rule the
world what can you do in the face of
such overwhelming power
there's no beating yoshi kagi kira for
villainy unlike other names mentioned
here he has no ambition to take over the
world or achieve immortality ultimately
he just wants to be left to his own
devices which include being a serial
killer and chopping off women's hands
yes he's a twisted soul which makes the
fact that he possesses one of the most
powerful stands in the series all the
more horrifying his explosive abilities
all taking their name from queen songs
allow him to detonate his victims either
directly in the case of killer queen or
remotely with sheer heart attack and
bites the dust there are certainly more
flamboyant villains in the jojo's
bizarre adventure pantheon but it's the
juxtaposition of the mundane and the
insane that makes yoshi kagakira one of
the best around on the one hand we spend
time watching him live a normal human
life taking walks in the park and being
generally comprehensible then however he
indulges his most twisted tendencies
unleashing killer queen in pursuit of
his sadistic desires he shows us the
kind of monster that can exist under the
most mundane of surfaces and that's why
he's an unforgettable villain check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite anime are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you